here's soon, genuinely bizarre video of Donald
Trump trying to make a point, I guess about
why he's taking vaping so seriously.
And he refers to his own son.
I mean, Barron Trump is his own son, at least
as far as we know as Melania's son.
And there's really no other way to introduce
it other than that.
This is following the trend of Trump seeming
to have no emotional connection to his own
children beyond the fact that many times he
said Ivanka has just an amazing body.
We've heard that from him before, but other
than that it's hard to really see him say
anything that suggests an emotional connection
to his kids.
Here's Trump.
I guess trying to explain why vaping is something
Melania is interested in being involved in.
Listen to how he refers to his own kid.
Uh, vaping has become a very big business
as I understand it, like a giant business
at a very short period of time.
But we can't allow people to get sick and
we can't have our youth be so effected.
And I'm hearing it and that's how the first
lady got involved and she's got a son together
that is a, a beautiful young man and she feels
very, very strongly about it.
She's seen it.
We're both reading it.
Is this the strangest way to refer to your
own kid?
Does anybody that anybody has ever heard Melania
cares about vaping because she has a son w
which is his son baron Trump.
She has a son and it is motivated her to care
about vaping.
Uh, someday maybe Trump would get a chance
to meet her son.
It almost sounds like the next thing he would
say would be this is a guy who either doesn't
care about his son nor respect his wife or
again, I mean, I, I know some people don't,
don't like this line, but um, is he experiencing
such cognitive decline that this is how he's
now referring to his own kids?
I've been, I'm not joking here.
I've been around people with Alzheimer's and
one of the things that happens is they will
get sometimes confused.
There will be people that they know are connected
to them in some way.
Family members or significant others or whatever
the case may be.
And they recognize that they know who the
person is.
There is a connection, but they refer to them
in a way where there's confusion about how
the person is connected to them.
They mentioned only the connection to others
as if they remember the person and one connection,
but not how they relate to that person.
This is exactly what Trump seems to be doing
here.
Now.
It may have nothing to do with that.
This may merely be a representation of how
little Trump cares about his own kid.
Any normal person who is either functioning
normally or is relating in a healthy way to
their wife and kid would say something like,
we have a wonderful son, or something along
those lines.
It wasn't a, my son is affected by this.
It's Melania.
Not even Alanya.
The first lady has a son and that's why she
cares about this.
Melania, by the way, didn't even react in
the sense that for her, she seems totally
acquainted with Donald Trump's complete lack
of interest in baron Trump and speaking of
kids, if she or he care about kids so much,
they've pulled flu vaccines from the border
camps.
He's lent credence to anti-vaccine ideas that
are extremely dangerous to children.
He bullies people on Twitter while his wife
claims that she's trying to work on stopping
bullying.
If having a kid makes her care so much about
children, there's plenty more that she could
be encouraging Donald Trump to do and really
take that seriously.
Some of the strangest video that I have seen
of Donald Trump, very, very, uh, bizarre.
Curious what you think
about it.